hi guys scifi recapped here before we
start warning
spoilers ahead today i'm going to
explain a 2017 science fiction movie
called time trap this movie has a very
unique concept about time so make sure
you watch it till the end the movie
begins with hopper an archaeology
professor and his dog boss are looking
for his family who disappeared after
descending in a cave while looking for
the fountain of youth back in the 1970s
he then notices there is a cave far in
the distance
upon arrival at the entrance of the cave
he sees a cowboy man whose gun and
attire don't seem to be from our
generation seemingly frozen in time
shocked with the discovery hopper turns
back and gets back home
apparently he had set up this
exploration trip with his teaching
assistants taylor and jackie but after
hopper arrives at home he tells them
that the situation has changed and the
professor decides to go back to the cave
alone
as hopper enters the cave he discovers
there is a layer that separates the
atmosphere between the outside world and
the cave
he decides to break through the lair and
the cowboy man he found at the previous
visit starts to move
it has been two days since the
professor's departure but until now
taylor and jackie haven't heard anything
from him so they decide to look for him
because they don't have their own suv
they call kara taylor's crush and ask
her to borrow her dad's suv
apparently thieves kara's sister also
has a school project to do so cara
decides to take her as well they are
also accompanied by vivsa's friend furby
yeah another child on a life-threatening
expedition because why not
the kids arrive and find hopper's
parents van where they discover that the
professor all this time is seeking for
his family at the cave not some hippies
from the 70s they were told before
they then find an old rope that leads
them into a different part of the cave
there they find the rope had been cut
off and learned that it is not hopper's
rope as it is already very old
they also discover that the cave is very
deep
the kids decide to descend further into
the cave leaving furby to keep watch
because he is too afraid to join them
while going down cara discovers the same
invisible layer that hopper found
earlier claiming that it changes the air
completely they decide to break through
the layer
back to hopper a moments later after he
follows the cowboy man he starts to feel
something strange
he notices a strange dance of light it
is as if someone is constantly dimming
and brightening the entrance of the cave
with a huge flash or something
after that he suddenly hears a screaming
voice and escapes from the cave
as we see previously hopper entered the
cave when the sun was still shining but
only less than five minutes inside the
outside world has become very different
as his car is covered by overgrowth
plans and it is already night it just
seems like a couple minutes in the cave
is equivalent to decades outside he also
finds cara's suv in jackie's backpack so
he decides to get back into the cave
back to the kids as they begin to
explore they suddenly hear screaming
voices and the girls decide to leave
from the cave starting with jackie but
the rope suddenly gets cut off and she
falls off injuring both jackie and
taylor who tries to save her
taylor then pulls the second rope
finding that one to be cut off as well
the group begins to think that it is
furby who purposely cuts the rope for
messing around
they try to communicate with furby from
the radio but he does not respond
eventually they hear some muffled sounds
from the radio asking for help claiming
that it is furby
left with no option the group decide to
move further inside the cave leaving the
injured jackie alone
at the other side of the cave the group
discovers a cut-off rope in furby's dead
body with a broken neck they then replay
the recording from furby's camera to see
what happened to him
furby reveals from the hopper's dad's
journal that the cave keeps magic water
that heals people because hopper's
sister got sick the family decides to go
to the cave looking for the water
after spending several days outside the
cave furby decides he is going to go and
looking for his friend who he's presumed
dead for the car keys
while it is a whole day for him the rest
of the group only experience seconds
inside the cave
as furby enters his rope gets cut
causing him to fall but doesn't die he
lies they're unconscious for about an
hour and wakes up to talk to taylor but
suddenly a caveman attacks and kills him
thieves also spot something nonsense as
the time code from the recording spans
several days while they only have been
in the cave for an hour
because both taylor and jackie are
injured only kara and thieves are left
to find a way out and call for help
because vives is younger karen decides
to climb up the same way they came down
and manages to come out to find a
completely different place
now there is no sign of vegetation and
the air also feels weird causing cara to
have difficulty breathing
she also spots a huge dust storm coming
her way she then discovers a massive
triangle-shaped object in the sky
unable to call for help she goes back
inside to the cave but is accused by
others for not even trying to get help
she is being accused because only a
couple of seconds had passed in the cave
while she had been outside for about 30
minutes
the group realizes that the time outside
the cave is running faster than inside
the cave causing the event inside the
cave to move more slowly taylor also
adds that the ropes at the top of the
cliff are aging at a rapid rate causing
them to sever due to the friction with a
cliff side because of that these
rewatches the recording of furby's
footage realizing that the sun paths
keep changing she also reveals that the
brightest summer in the dark is winter
making one cycle of season seen in only
about one second which means an entire
year passes by in only a second
so we can calculate and discover that
approximately 5 400 years have passed on
the earth since they have been in the
cave
when cara attempts to climb on the cliff
one more time suddenly a very futuristic
and high-tech ladder pops down into the
cave along with a giant being covered in
spacesuit out of nowhere a caveman
appears and begins to attack the giant
but is subdued down lethally the group
decides to run away to another part of
the cave
there they find the dead bodies of the
cowboy man and hopper's parents
they are also confronted by three other
cavemen taylor decides to fight the
cavemen but is killed brutally all the
girls flee to the other side of the cave
cara comes back and finds his dead body
while crying over him she is confronted
by the alien giant he picks up taylor's
body and drags him to the pool of water
magically the water manages to bring
taylor back to life
the caveman come back and attack the
giant knocking off his helmet which
exposes him to the air he is not able to
breathe
even so he still manages to capture all
the cavemen before he dies he shows the
group several media clips about their
disappearance and indicating that humans
have begun to move to another planet in
order to preserve humanity at this point
the group realizes that there is no way
back and they must decide whether they
have to get out there right now or live
there forever
but taylor eventually finds a mortally
injured hopper in front of another
thicker layer of wall containing
hopper's long missing sister and frozen
folks from various eras who are fighting
to seize the youth fountain hopper
explains that the whole cave is a system
which was designed to protect the
fountain in each layer has a different
speed making the time in the deeper
layer much slower than the previous
layer the group uses the water to heal
the injured jackie and dead furby but
they are being attacked by the remaining
caveman
since they have nowhere to go they
decide to use the high-tech ladder from
the giant to climb outside the cave
as they reach the cave's mouth they
discover that the entrance has been
filled by water cara tries to break
through the lair but suddenly is yanked
by strange creatures which turns out
later to be a further evolved human a
moments later a fully suited carer
returns to the cave followed by
high-tech rope to retrieve everyone from
the cave including furby hopper and
hopper's parents
at the end of the film furby hopper his
parents and sister are all brought back
to life
they are now on the bigger spaceship
that is headed towards the new earth or
whatever they are calling it
subscribe to watch more videos like this
turn on notifications and leave a like
to help the channel out thank you for
watching